are you hungry because here's some food
yeah bon appetit's annual list of best
restaurants is taking a new form this
year first on cbs mornings we are
revealing bon appetit's head of the
table list it features 12 trailblazing
leaders changing the industry from chefs
and restaurant owners to non-profits and
a politician one of those philadelphia's
down north pizza which serves
detroit-style pizza and provides a way
for previously incarcerated people to
get back on their feet
my name is michael carter i'm an
executive chef at down north pizza
download pizza is a mission-based
for-profit restaurant where we combat
recidivism by offering a job exclusively
to formally incarcerate it everybody in
the building has been in the pain most
people won't even look at you twice once
they find out that you've been
incarcerated and down north we created
an environment where you don't have to
hide who you are
we want to bring these people home and
have them stay home and how can you do
that by providing as many resources as
possible
in philadelphia they said the living
wage is about 7.75 so we double that and
we start everybody off at 15 an hour
basically we're offering a fast casual
restaurant where you can actually be
proud that it's in your neighborhood
this is just the beginning to uh kind of
empowering the neighborhood and you know
rebuilding this neighborhood that's been
broken for years if you come for the
food you're going to get the mission and
if you come for the mission you're going
to get the food it just works together
[Music]
it's not just some ex-cons
that's making pizza no it's some ex-cons
making good pizza
okay
and we are joined now by bon appetit's
editor-in-chief dawn davis who gail king
is currently talking to about where she
wants to eat well first i'm looking at
dawn's dress i want that and then i also
want to go to the pizza place i love the
concept and it look i wanted to lick the
screen that's only one of how much we're
on this list we have 12
tables head to the table okay so this is
a little bit different than what you
typically do usually it's the hot
restaurants of the year which can change
the trajectory of a restaurant to get on
that list but last year was different so
you guys went a different way tell us
about it yeah in a year of unprecedented
change we thought we had to evolve our
thinking around what makes for a great
restaurant and so we thought about the
community leaders the community builders
and really the people who were changing
what makes for a good restaurant and
those are people who take care of their
community
and you said that because normally you
guys travel all around the country so
obviously you couldn't do that but i
like that you get your ideas from many
different places including our own
michelle miller who came up with a
suggestion for you and it made the list
who guaranteed herself free meals at
lucille
for all of eternity yeah she has no
investment in lucille's what did she say
so we i had an editorial team we had a
brainstorm and i asked for people to
give me their ideas of who were the
thought leaders who was you know helping
out in their community and michelle
miller had mentioned if you're going to
do something on a cool chef you have to
feature chris williams and what i love
is that he makes fantastic food he's
traveled the world and his global
influences show up in his restaurant in
houston but he also takes care of the
elderly he took care of essential
workers when texas had a shutdown he
opened his really beautiful patio to
other restaurants and said take over the
bar and keep all of the profits and he
continues to work
with other institutions and
organizations that are helping the food
insecure so he is the epitome to me
ahead of the table all right so you look
for people that who not only have good
food but are doing good things yeah no
doubt about i want to talk about the lee
initiative um you know and it started in
2017 support women in kentucky who are
in the beginning stages of their
restaurant careers but they shifted
their focus during the pandemic how so
yeah so ed lee has a great restaurant
magnolia 610 in louisville and but he
wanted to do more he started helping
women but then he thought this is an
opportunity to help farmers to help food
professionals to help restaurateurs and
restaurants he also helps black culinary
professionals as well entrepreneurs in
the food space helping with millions of
dollars and really just thinking broadly
about how to kind of see the next
generation of leaders you know what i
like i like the writing and bon appetit
because you go i'm not sure how much
longer it'll be normal to say this but
it's been a weird year we all feel that
and you talk about something called
there's no us
no us without you what is that well i
want to give a shout out to elisa mine
who is our restaurant editor who put
that together and who wrote that piece
know us without ula is an organization
we all love chefs we glorify them in the
pages of bon appetit but as emeril
lagasse has said and tony bourdain said
it's the dishwashers and the busters who
are the heart the operational heart of a
restaurant without them restaurant
service wouldn't last an hour and so no
us without ula within 24 hours of the
pandemic started an organization that
supports back of the house workers and
we're really proud to feature this
fantastic and by the way bon appetit is
not just fancy food my favorite page in
this new magazine is the family meal
page here with bulgur
and i love this quote bulgur is the
canned margarita of grains ready to
party fast
i love that mind tony is the audacity of
opening a restaurant during a pandemic
number one i like that section there's
one in new york called guys vestry okay
that's when you take the magazine look
at that chicken and the vestry it's also
on the cover the chicken fancy chicken
on the cover and then i thought it was a
scallop but it's a chicken
vestry is fantastic it's a restaurant in
soho you know we talk a lot about the
hundreds of thousands of restaurants
that close during the pandemic but some
people had the audacity to open for
different reasons they wanted to build
community they wanted to focus on
something positive they saw less
competition so we feature five
restaurants from all over the country
yeah and we're really excited to feature
them awesome and bravo to you don davis
new editor-in-chief at bon appetit
i salute you bravo thank you so much
thanks for having me here